on this episode my homie Brian stops by
and talks about his new book
[Music]
[Music]
yes
Guerry be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 162 of
the askgaryvee show this is a very
special episode because I just got off
the plane from my family vacation for my
40th birthday so this is the first
episode in my 40s I'm also here with a
very dear friend as a matter of fact
Stefon I'm gonna have you make an edit
there has to be video of your last
button what that was your last book that
was two books ago what there's video
that somewhere it's a bunch of show
little cut this is us in our younger
days Brian we have none other than Gary
Vaynerchuk I got a book
Thank You economy you ever heard of it
from what I hear it's the greatest
business book written of all time so I
think you made a very wise $13 all right
that was good I'll get you that clip
Stephan and Brian once you want you tell
the vaynernation who you are it's really
good to have you here I'm glad we made
it happen well you know I knew of a new
book which is really the only reason my
friends stopped by the askgaryvee show
is to sell their books of the
vaynernation which i respect because in
march i will be stopping by everybody's
house you won't be stopped selling but
if if it means a lot though I'm actually
here to officially welcome so you can
join my club although I think I look a
lot younger you do man you've no grace
how old are you right I am 44 look good
man well it's the oil of olay who uses
red wine actually is it a little [ __ ]
that I should look 13 didn't work for me
oh wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute you have to we continue the trend
of a vein I apologize a vaynermedia
employee we're just talking about
Orlando's a vaynermedia employee joining
each episode so why don't you tell the
Vayner nation who you are and say hello
what you do and all that different yeah
very different enjoying thanks for
joining us
yeah I'll keep going well yeah so we've
transitioned quick here Brad I'm ready
clutch in so I'm a digital analyst I
work at a place called altimeter group
we study disruptive technology its
impact on business I'm also a digital
anthropologist setting you can
disruptive technologies in fact none of
us have a new book out and some gorgeous
man credibly ironic technology and I'm
gonna write a book so look at this took
about three and a half years this is me
this was three and half years yeah
because I studied UX UI and a lot of
attention spans focus sentence structure
and sort of trying to reinvent what a
book could be in 2016
interesting and so it's designed after
some of the most popular apps no table
of contents it's all like a interesting
yeah it's about experiences so I thought
if I'm going to talk about experiences
the book should be an experience cool
good for you man how's it going so far
wouldn't they come out it just came out
it's going I think it's going good yeah
just come out like a week ago last
Tuesday
yeah so let's see how this a week from
tonight how does it do that
you know how Amazon it so whatever it
gets it all the book stuff Stefan let's
link that up in Facebook and YouTube
vaynernation
we've had people come through so you
know where my words sit on this Brian is
an early friend of mine from the early
kind of like when I entered the tech
space a quality human being you know I'm
a fan I'm you know I don't read books by
as you know which is weird it but I'm
positive that you put in good effort I
know that this was definitely you burned
a lot of books yes so this one seems to
be the biggest break in time is that do
you feel great about that like do you
feel like this one you put in more work
than the norm kind of I mean there's
some truth to that yeah no I
it was I felt like I was losing
relevance along the way you know I'm
trying to find other you know media to
sort of stay in front of people but I
also thought that I wanted to take the
time to do it right because you know if
the point of the book is to create
experiences that matter to people today
and that people are different than the
book itself how to do that
let me get into a ramp good I like to
rent my number one favorite thing of all
time is everybody who consults and gives
advice on using new technologies to sell
stuff and then their books don't sell
like I've I like to me if the askgaryvee
book is not a mat doesn't sell a lot of
copies then like what is my butt and to
your point there right like if your if
your own like behavior doesn't map the
thesis you're dead like and so like i am
sure that you probably i noticed you
brought a mechanism a great agency like
you probably took a lot of thought about
that oh yeah look i set the weight not
just as author but also acted as an art
director as researcher to figure it out
because it is my pet peeve to go rant so
many authors talk about the future and
how to be different but they don't
they're not different right I mean we
this is so different it's the shape of
an iPad air 2 we had to come up with
holding printing processes the paper you
know if you just look at the color
saturation on the poor jamming printers
everywhere good good job my wife is a
wily good job my wily willing to allow
you to like produce this right yeah they
had a bet well you know they give
mechanism and I a shot and I mean it's
it's just what's cool is if you swipe
right on it somewhat alright India it is
time to get into the show show show
yeah well I'm classy in my 40s let's do
it
Andrew ass how do you distinguish
between bad marketing strategy that's
not working and just having a crappy
product I've got it so Andrews been
watching enough to know that I talked a
lot about like even the best marketing
in the world isn't gonna fix your crap
product so he's asking how do we
decipher why you want to take a shot at
that or you want me to go you go and all
you know to me it's pretty easy there's
only those two things at some level and
so I think what you do first is if
you're unsure you change your entire
marketing approach and I would say you
do that twice so over a 12 to 24 month
period you change your marketing
approach radically if you go over
three there is chances that your
marketing sucked all three times but it
is starting to give you an indication
that nobody wants your pet rock or your
iPhone case that glows in the dark
or your crappy wine that you made so the
other thing to do is to look at your
lifetime value and repeat business one
of the reasons I know that Wine Library
works is we have incredible lifetime
value and a lot of repeat business so
then the waves of that business are
usually predicated on the marketing
because once we get people in they stay
and so I think we can feel that as
people that write books that you look at
your numbers this week and you probably
will look at like historically since
you've written seven what's your most
successful book and the business as
usual and engage where I think the most
excel it so like to me like it's funny I
think Thank You economy is the best book
I wrote but it's the least successful
and I look back at like yeah I gave it
the less oh it by far the least oath
because I was deep in the starting of
running vaynermedia so I I think you
look at lifetime value and repeat
business and what your product is
because if people are coming in and
they're using it and buying or
what-have-you
well then you just need to figure out
how to get more of them in if you're
getting a ton of people in but you're
not getting any longtail action that's
your vulnerability and I think we live
in a time of social media right and the
key part of that is social so I think
some of the best marketing starts before
the marketing right and so listening
talking being inspired by people through
all these technologies that humanize
people again in humanize communities I
think you can actually take that insight
and build better products and and build
not just products but the products that
are experiences so that you can invest
in relationships and lifetime value and
retention as well as acquisition love it
let's move it
India Elton says hey Gary what do you
think about the crying emoji being the
Oxford word of the year communication
shift I'm thrilled I'm so fired up about
this you can't even imagine
I I think it's an important signal I've
been talking about communication
shifting I use emojis with 50 60
year-olds in the crowd saying how many
of you used emoji I just did a talk in
Orlando ironically two days before I
went I had a fly back and forth for the
Thursday night game I told you I was
right about that Bill's jets Stefan
fire with my predictions anyway a little
quick shout out for all you Houston
Texans fans I'll be in the stadium on
Sunday as well flying in and out for
that game going to every game this year
I think I've decided I'm pumped I think
it's a great significant step it's it's
a it's a headline that a lot of people
gonna come across over the next 48 hours
and it continues the the thing that I
care about the most which is eliminating
romance and just dealing with the
reality the world's changing pictures
are clearly becoming a way we
communicate emojis obviously a lot of it
happened in Asia where the keypads and
transitioned over here listen we used to
draw on caves like inside caves we drew
on them did they get mad when the words
came along like I'm sure there's like
grandpa caveman was like they [ __ ]
like we should always draw on cave these
words are bad we get used to our norms
you know and a hundred years from now
when we're only doing emoji like things
and words are less used I mean do you
know how much better my life is that I
actually misspell things on purpose and
let autocorrect fix them I don't know
man so we're spelling it properly I just
want to get my words to somebody oh we
live at a time when a magazine is an
iPad that doesn't work so it'll work to
you the folks at Oxford I will give you
this response love it love it
Joel ass Gary what does the future look
like for the auto industry will local
car dealers be cut out of the business
model it's a great question
look I think direct-to-consumer over a
50-year period is very real and so
anybody who's an including what I do for
a living like selling wine and liquor
like I do believe that the Internet is
the middleman period and I think a lot
of industries just haven't been affected
by it yet so the hotel industry has been
affected by it
a or B me the the car you know the the
black car industry has been affected by
it the bookstore industry has been
affected by it systematically over the
next half century most of the things
that sell to customers will be affected
by it and I think auto is employment
look Tesla's selling direct I mean so I
think that um yes I do think now I think
way too many people think about things
and they think
gonna happen tomorrow I've learned that
that's what I've learned now that I'm 40
and wise when I was 20 I would have my
20 year old self was sitting here since
Brian looks 20 according to Brian I'll
say Brian I'll say Gary
20 year old Gary not everything's gonna
happen as fast as you think and that's
the thing I've learned that takes time
but do I think over a 50 year period
absolutely if you're asking is a 48 year
old who owns a car dealership I don't
think you need to sell it tomorrow but
if you're asking as a 12 year old who
want to take over grandpappies
dealership you may want to consider
going in a different direction than
they're trying to triple down on the
model right I love car dealerships look
I just actually came off some research
with Google about this and we studied
the moments of truth of how the the
highly digital customer shops for cars
and I think there's an opportunity for
dealerships to be relevant in today's
society it's not based on yesterday's
model
so I just show my new kicks good but if
you study this look up Auto shopping
micro-moments and you will start to see
exactly where you can add relevance and
value to the value chain but if you do
not
Tesla like models are gonna take over
and it's just inevitable people need to
get what they want when they want it how
they want it and things have been flow
right like like you used to have the
downtown market like the Main Street
America then we went to the suburbs and
we have you know supermarkets and
Costco's and now more than ever people
are moving back into the cities the
Detroits way of the world and now you
have Main Street merging again so ABS
inflows ebbs and flows and so technology
overlaying that is gonna cause a lot of
disruption over the next 50 years and I
do think the direct consumer model is
very real it's just economically sound
for the people that take the biggest
risk who are the people that actually
make this crap I think that just
reminded me of clueless where the role
in with my home rolling with the homies
god I love that movie Joseph asks Gary
how do you analyze all the social media
data that you get every day personally
and corporately what's the corporately
part like how does vaynermedia do it
versus me
I do it completely on what got me here
in the first place and Bryant you know
this might be interesting Brian and be
interesting this is probably to make me
feel good but you can go anywhere you
want with it you have an interesting
perspective because you were actually
there when my thing happened there's not
that many people that were so you know I
did it back then on feel I was right
about a lot of things intuitively and
that's what I do now I mean I just read
it I read my feeds I read my comments I
look at the engagement levels on what
I'm putting out so I'm an analyst on my
own stuff Vayner as a corporate entity
is doing it much more excel sheet than
gut feel than I am they're analyzing
numbers deeper they're converting that
into a report for their clients I'm sure
you guys do similar stuff but me
personally I'm just reading it like I'm
watching how fast I get likes on
Instagram when it's convenient not every
post you know if I'm on a plane and I do
it right before I take off and as soon
as I get the Wi-Fi I can look at it like
there's there's kind of serendipity to
the way I analyze but I'm feeling it
I was very intuitive in the way I
marched you know six seven eight nine a
lot of things those things worked out I
continued to do that
I can look I'm doing it even with this
show if you're noticing Brian is now at
the culmination of a period here where
we brought in a lot of guests by
comparison so I'm always testing and
learning looking at the comments trying
to understand trying to vibe with it
right you know the one thing I will say
about you as your friend is that you've
always cared right so at a time where
we've come up with a lot of people over
the years that just really tried to buy
the hyper create the hype and really try
to grow their fan bases and and all of
that activity without actually adding
value to the community
you're still hustling probably harder
than ever before maybe more than you did
early on you take that feedback i watch
this you take that feedback you actually
do something with it you do shows like
this where you can add value to people's
lives at people's streams with
everything that you do so I think your
metric system is just sort of a
validation of the fact that you're
listening to people and trying to give
back to the community that's evident and
you should be reward with it
you like that idea and by the way I have
been asked by nine hundred people to sit
in this seat and do this and we've been
at six and like five
I've been one of them was my
father-in-law so it's not you know I
think it speaks to your ways well and
then there's all the behind the scenes
stuff that you and I know which is
there's the business stuff and you could
be very business oriented there's a good
lesson for you a lot of youngsters
there's the black and white business
stuff like yo homie support my book sure
I could do that but there's just life
right like when somebody's sick when you
post something on your Facebook that
you're having a tough time or the all
the people that we share in common that
we've never sat in the same room with
that how they talk about us to each
other when we get brought up in a
setting right it's all those other
things that are part of the equation as
well you know I think if it's one thing
I've learned along along this journey is
is to constantly give more than you take
and and 5149 treat people in ways that
make them feel more special when they
leave and engage with you and then the
last is just live and act and breathe as
as if you want people to talk about you
when you're not in the room in a way
that's complimentary 100 percent legacy
and brand meet ass hi Gary it seems like
everyone speaks about not giving up no
matter what but how do you know when
it's time to let it go so I'm gonna you
know this is something I struggle with
like having a loss on your resume is so
scary and the business ventures that
I've had in the past where I wasn't
actively running and I've talked about
porked or Forrest Lindsey and Kyle
amazing entrepreneurs that I don't feel
that I supported enough and thus those
two obsessed TV with samantha ettus
where i trying to produce a video show
that didn't start me i never was able to
give it enough energy and the thing that
i spent the most time with is when do i
let it go because there's a point where
you realize by the way i realize this
with employees there don't you know i
know a lot of vaynermedia employees
watch this but i'm gonna tell the truth
there's five to six employees that i
think it might be time to not work
together anymore and do i struggle with
that boy do i struggle with that one
mainly because i don't like letting
other people down more than anything the
truth is meat i think it's a very
personal answer i think it depends on
every individual but what I will say is
way too many people watching this right
now are holding on to hope
non-reality or don't want to make
somebody feel bad or don't want to have
the reputation of having a loss on their
record and I think it's a huge mistake
and it's probably the mistake that I'm
most vulnerable to and as I think about
my next 40 years of executing and you're
right I am hustling more than ever I'm
feeling more fit and energized and feel
like I'm gonna really go into my golden
year especially the next 20 years that's
just the truth
don't sure what I'm 60 I'm like this is
what I'm really gonna do it
I do think that that LED this is a
tremendous question of so god damn
pumped that this happened on my 40th
birthday episode first one this is the
one thing that I'm spending a lot of
time on I think it's hard but it is I
think more people have to let go more
often and the two things I'm working on
are both ends of that saying no more
often because boy that's hard for me and
then letting go more often and really
zoning in on that middle is my answer to
that so the punchline is very personal
but because I want to bring value to
everybody listening what's up podcasters
and watching I really think that a lot
of you need to take this question use it
as a moment use it as permission let me
be your olive branch a link to this part
of the show as the excuse or the flame
that let you do it there's a lot of
people that need to let go and if I can
add one thing to that would be you know
what this book is probably the first
time where I felt like I was gonna fail
you know in a while interesting because
you wouldn't because you had to do the
work it wasn't like what naturally was
in you right it was natural it was
naturally in me which is right another
book you know and and I thought I would
be doing that and in three and a half
years in the making right there were I
mean even up until six weeks before it
was done I thought it's not gonna happen
meaning what like just so many things
were going wrong you know in terms of
production and printing processes and
finding the right shapes and paper I
mean everything about it also relearning
how to write sentences I mean like I did
I was beaten and there was the same that
I end of mine the day arrest he had told
me that in entrepreneurship it's always
darkest before the dawn
mm-hm and I thought that you know maybe
maybe that is it maybe maybe this was
just a
tats to go a little bit further and see
them through but at the same time it was
the right thing to do but at the same
time there are moments when you have to
walk away and just try to learn from
them because that's all anybody wants
from you is to show that you tried and
that you learned from something and you
did it better or get it differently the
next time appreciated my friend as the
guest of today's show you get to ask the
vaynernation I've been back to the
question of the day you get to ask them
any question this is a great opportunity
I know you like focus groups and data
but be a lot of answers on YouTube and
Facebook and I'll send you the link so
you can go through them here's your shot
you want to make the theme of that your
thing whatever you want to go with just
even my homework is you know if you
could maybe close your eyes and think
about you know when's the last time you
had a really great experience with with
something whether it was a brand or a
service or what was it do you have one
India what made it so special
do you have one yeah I'm like something
really what was no no do you have a I'm
sorry a great experience the last great
exploit you can do you have something
that's like just so obvious yeah I'm not
trying to put you look at it's
interesting it all depends on what you
decide the pull of the four seasons is
where I stayed with my family there was
a problem and that was the opportunity
for the great experience I mean I've
secretly thought that you should do
things wrong on purpose because I think
there's more upside in the fixing a
mistake than just the enormous status
like if you're just crushing it as
arrest nobody hears like oh this
restaurant because they consistent let's
say there's a restaurant you go to that
consistently hits it on a 9.5 on the
scale of the world 9.5 you know in
saying that is like it is on point nope
after the third or fourth time you just
take it for granted like if you went
there the first time and like the waiter
spilled red wine over your beautiful
dress India be cool cuz she wears black
and so you wouldn't be able to see it
but but like if you you know you got
something tonight you know if that
happened and then they comped the whole
meal and like pick you up and carry you
to your car or give you okay it's so
funny to me that mistake first fixing
mistake is a greater experience for a
lot of people I would add on as a point
be a great experience
that wasn't predicated on a problem at
first love having your own brother by
the book he deserves it a good man
actually coming on you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering them
[Music]